مجلس الحقوق الانسان في الامم المتحده
والبرلمان الاوروبيه يبحثان اليوم
انتهاكات ايران لحقوق الانسان
وتهديد سلامه العسكريين الامريكيين
بغداد تعتزم اعاده نشر قوتها على الحدود
مع ايران وتركيا بالتنسيق مع حكومه اقليم
كردستان
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الي
نشره الاهم الانباب من العربيه
يعقد البرلمان الاوروبي اليوم
في ظل انتهاكات النظام لحقوق الانسان
حاله الطوارئ الخاصه بحقوق الانسان في
ايران في ظل تصعيد الامن للعنف ضد
المحتاجين
كما اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض
عقوبات على ثلاثه مسؤولين امنيين ايرانيين
وتعلقوا هذه العقوبات بانتهاك حقوق
الانسان
ذلك الى حمله طهران الامنيه ضد المحتجين
والاجراءات العدوانيه المتزايده ضد الشعب
الايراني بحسب الوزراء
وهو في المدن الكرديه تحولت شوارع الى صحه
حرب المواجهات بين المحتاجين وقوات الامن
ومع تصاعدي ضخم الاحتجاجات دعا نشطاء
للاضراب العامه
الله اكبر فيها
كردستان العراق اشارت الى ان اكثر من 80
متظاهرا قتلوا وتوكل 4
في المناطق ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه وحدها
تحدثت بمنظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران التي
تتخذ من اوزلومه قرر لها في اخر حصيله
اصدرتها عن مصرع 72 شخصا الاسبوع الماضي
وحده وبينهم 56 في مناطق يقتلها الاكراد
بالغرب وثقت لجنه متابعه معتقلين في ايران
شل النظام الايراني حمله اعتقالات واسعه
في مدن مهابات
الكرديه ومدينه ايران شهر في بلوشستان
ووسط تقارير تفيد بقمع وانتهاكات جسيمه
يقوم بها نظام الايراني ضد المعتقلين في
سجونه وثقت مفاوضيه حقوق الانسان
الى الاحتجاجات السلميه ندعو ايران لاطلاق
سراح المعتقلين واسقاط التهامي الموجهه
اليهم ونطالبها بتعليق فوري لعقوبه
الاعدام
حملت القمع الايرانيه اتخذت استراتيجيه
شاذه في محاوله لكبح متظاهرين من التعذيب
والاعدام وحتى الاغتصاب
فقد كشفت شبكه سي ان الامريكيه وفقا لشهود
في التقرير
قوه الامن داخل السجون الى تصوير بعض
مشاهد العنف الجنسي لاستخدامها اداه
لابتزاز المتظاهرين واسكاتهم امر دفع
السلطات الامريكيه والاوروبيه للتنديد
والمطالبه بمحاسبه المسؤول الى ان النظام
الايراني لا يزال مسرا على نفيه تلك
التهاب
داخليا لم يفرق مع النظام المتظاهرين عن
الاستمرار باحتجاجاتهم واستدعوات للاضراب
العام اطلقها نشطاء ايرانيون بدايه من
الغد تنديدا بقمع قوه الامن المحتجين في
المدن الكرديه
بلاش
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عربه وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه عن
قصف التركيه الاخيره على العراق
وكان قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم
عبدي دعا جيش النظام للقتال معهم لمواجهه
تركيا
ضعيف وغير واضح ازاء الهجوم التركي عبده
يوضح ان قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه اوقفت
التنسيق مع التحالف الدولي والقتال ضد
داعش اضافه لتاثر التنسيق مع روسيا وذلك
بسبب الهجمات التركيه
داخليا وعلى الارض يهتز شمال الغربي في
تركيا بسبب زلزال يضرب تلك المناطق
اما خارجيا وعلى الحدود الجنوبيه الشرقيه
تهتز الارض شمالي سوريا والعراق لكن بسبب
الضربات الجويه التركيه هناك
العمليه التي وصفت بالاكبر والاشمل
والاكثر فاعليه في شمالي العراق وسوريا
واسفرت عن تحييد 254 مسلحا واصابت 401
هدفا وزاره الدفاع التركيه
والطائرات بدون طياره ليست سوى البدايه
وعيد بمزيد من الضربات بموازاه القصف
الجوي والمدفعيه الى زحف القوات البريه
وفي الوقت المناسب بحسب الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان وذلك ما يخشاه النظام السوري
الذي تتزايد مخاوفه من تكرار الرئيس
التركي تحذيراته من ان جيشه قد ينفذ
تواغلا بريا جديدا في سوريا وهو امر تعهدت
القوات الكرديه المدعومه من الولايات
المتحده بالتصدي لها مقابل حتى روسيا
لتركيا بالتحلي النفس والانتناعي عن شنه
هجوم بري واسع النطاق في سوريا
فيما تثير الضربات التركيه التوتر مع
النظام السوري ايضا اضافه الى ان تلك
الضربات التركيه اصابت مواقع لجيش النظام
السوري اسفرت عن مقتل واصابه جنود ضربات
قد تلغي الاتفاق الضني في الخصومه ضد
الاكراد السوريين بين انقره ودمشق دمشق
التي تعارض سيطره الاكراد على نحو ثلث
اراضي البلاد ومنها الشرق الغني بالنفط
لتظلم واقع الاكراد في الشمال السوري كما
العراقي ايضا بؤره لصراع مشتعل على الدواء
اعلن العراق عاصمه اعاده نشر قوتها على
حدوده مع كل من ايران وتركيا في قرار ان
ياتي بعد القصف المتكرر الذي نفذته طهران
وانقره وطال عددا من المناطق في اقليم
كردستان العراق
وقالت الحكومه العراقيه في بيان صدر بعد
اجتماع للمجلس الوزاري للامن الوطني انها
قررت وضع خطه لاعاده نشر قوات الحدود
العراقيه لمسكن الخط الصفري على طول
الحدود مع ايران وتركيا
بتنسيق مع حكومه اقليم كردستان العراق
وزاره
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
منافساته كاس العالم تدخل يومها الخامس
ومنتخب اليابان يصنع المفاجاه امام
المانيا بعد مفاجاه السعوديه على
الارجنتين
اهلا بكم من جديد اجلت محكمه الجراحه
الابتدائيه التونسيه الناظره في القضيه
المتعلقه بعقود اللوبين
داخل الحركه رفيق عبد السلام وكان الغنوشي
لم يحضر جلسه امس فيما قررت هيئه الدائره
تاخير النظر في القضيه الى شهر يناير
المقبل
تمويل الخارجي
ايضا في تونس قررت الحكومه رفع اسعار
الوقود ليرتفع سعر اللتر من دينارين و 400
مليم الى دينارين و 525 ملي من وذلك بنسبه
تزيد عن ال 5% قرار رفع اسعار الوقود
والخامس من نوع منذ بدايه العام الجاري
حيث تسعى الحكومه لتلبيه متطلبات صندوق
النقد الدولي برفع الدعم عن عدد من السلع
والمنتجات الاساسيه خاصه المحروقات التي
ارتفعت اسعارها في الاسواق الدوليه منذ
بدايه ازمه الاوكراني
تطورات وتغيرات متلاحقه ومتسارعه وصاحب
قضيه تويتر لكن ثابته حتى الان هو رضوى
الشركه الرد
قناه العربيه
الذي قال ان مرحله الاقالات قد انتهت
والان ستبدا مرحله التوظيف واعطى الاولويه
لتوظيف المهندسين والتوظيف في قسم
المبيعات
اختلفت عليه القرع
اعتقد ان الامر فريده هناك كثيرون تمت
اقالتهم ثم الان هناك توظيف لاشخاص جدد قد
يكون ذلك امرا جيدا لمعرفه ما يمكن تعيينه
اذا كنت لا تريد العوده الى العمل
والاحتفاظ به فهناك كثيرون في المدينه
يبحثون عن وظيفه
باكثر من قيمتها والان يختلق الامور وسيصل
الى مرحله لا تكون لديه سنه نقديه
حاولنا خلال الايام الماضيه اكثر من مره
ان نتواصل مع احد في الشركه لكن رجال
الامن هنا الامن المنطقه يمنعوننا سنحاول
مره اخرى الدخول الى ااا الشركه لنتواصل
مع احد المديرين او احد الموظفين الذين
يمكن ان يساعدونا على فهم ما يجري اكثر
خاصه في ظل التطورات الاخيره نحن الان
نقترب من باب الشركه همم اشاهد ان البعض
يشير الينا ربما يقترب منا ايه موظفون
الامن وبالفعل هذا ما يحدث الان ليمنعنا
لا اعرف لماذا لا يقبلون التحدث لا يعطون
اي اشاره او ذلك
اوكي
نج
ده اوك
اوك اوك
اوك
هذا ما يجري دائما معنا عندما يشاهدون
الكاميرا ياتون ويحاولون منعنا من الدخول
في المرات السابقه حتى عندما اتيت بدون
كاميرا رفضوا التحدث اليه عندما عرفوا
انني من الصحافه يعني هذا هو الحال الحالي
هنا في تويتر هناك محاوله دائما
لتغطيه على ما يجري على ما يبدو اا ما ما
يرشح عن الشركه هي تسريبات بعد الموظفين
الذين تكلمون لكن بشرط ان لا همم تذكر
اسمائهم ولكن هؤلاء همم التواصل معه ثاني
يكون صعب يخوفهم من ان يعرف همم يعرفون او
شيء من هذا القبيل الحسين الطاود من امام
مقر تويتر سنه فرنسي
تدخلوا بوراسات وكاس العالم يومها الخامس
وفي يومه الرابع فجر منتخب اليابان مفاجاه
بفوز على منتخب المانيا في محقق المنتخب
الاسباني فوزا كبيرا على كوستاريكا
ببطوله العالم بعد تغلبه على كوستاريكا
بسبعه اهداف من دون مقابل اسبانيا الشوط
الاول متقدمه بثلاثه اهداف من دون رد قبل
ان تضيف اربعه اهداف في الشوط الثاني
لتنزع اول ثلاث نقاط لها في نسخه الحديثه
اصغر لاعب يسجل في تاريخ البطوله بعد
البرازيلي اسبانيا تقابل المانيا الاحد
المقبل تلعب مع اليابان
[تصفيق]
منتخب اليابان فجر مفاجاه جديده في كاس
العالم بفوزه على منتخب المانيا بهدفين
مقابل هدف ضمن منافسات المجموعه الخامسه
نجحت اليابان في قلب تاخرها بهدف
جزاء الى فوزن بهدفين سجلهما البديلان
ريتس رضوان لاعب فرايبرج الالماني وزميله
تاكوما اسانو الالماني ايضا علما بان
قائمه منتخب اليابان تتضمن سمان يتلاعبين
من الانديه المانيا
في جوله المقبله منتخب اسبانيا في السابع
والعشرين من الشهر الحالي
[تصفيق]
تعال بقى المنتخب البلجيكي على نظيره
الكندي بهدف من دون مقابل الجوله الاولى
من المجموعه السادسه المنتخب الكندي ضغط
على شياطين الحمر في الشوط الاول واحضر
ديفيدس ركله جزاء تصدى لها بنجاح الحارس
كما كان باتشواي من تسجيل الهدف الوحيد
لابناء المدرب روبرتو مارتينيز ليمنح
بلادهم نقاط الثلاث المنتخب البلجيكي
يواجه الاحد المقبل المغرب ضمن جوله
الثانيه
[تصفيق]
واصبح
لاعب منتخب كندا اكبر لاعب يشاركه اساسيا
في تاريخ كاس العالم باستثناء حراس المرمى
لعب بشكتاش التركي في سن التاسعه
والثلاثين وتسعه اشهر كسر رقم الارجنتيني
عن خلال برونا الذي شارك بنسخه 58 وكان
الكاميرونيرو جيميلا قد شارك في كاس
العالم 94 وهو يبلغ اثنين واربعين عاما
الا انه لم يشارك اساسيا في اي مباراه
حقق المنتخب المغربي تعادل من دون اهداف
امام منتخب كرواتيا وصيف بطل العالم ضمن
مباريات المجموعه السادسه تنتقل المغرب مع
بلجيكا الاحد المقبل قبل مواجهه كندا في
ملعب التمامه ويسعى منتخب الاسود لتجاوز
دور المجموعات وتكرار انجاز 86 عندما بلغ
دور 16
وحصل نجم ريال مدريد ولاعب منتخب كرواتيا
لوكا مودريتش على جائزه افضل لاعب في
المباراه وكان مودريتش قد شارك في
المباراه كامله لكن من دون ان يساهم في اي
هدف خلال اللقاء الذي انتهى بالتعادل
السلبي
[موسيقى]
احنا طمعنا
في نقطه
لكن
المنتخب الكواشي وسيف ديال بطل العالم
ديال النسخه اللي فاتت مقابله يعني جيده
كتعرف بان كرواتيا واحد الفريق رواسي
الحمد لله
الماتش الجاي ان شاء الله
الرياضي شكرا لمتابعتكم تحياتي
[موسيقى]
للمنتخب السعودي
امام رفاق الاسطوره ليونيل ميسي
الحفظ التاريخي للاخضر السعودي على
المنتخب الارجنتيني في المونديال مازال
حديث الكل ويثير ردود الافعال ثنائيه امام
منتخب مرشح لاحراز اللقب جعلت الصحافه
العالميه تفتح قاموس المدح وتستعمل كلماته
للتعبير عن اداء ابهر الجميع امام رفاق
صاحب الكره الذهبيه السبع انها اللدغه
العربيه هكذا عنوانه صحيفه البريطانيه صدر
صفحتها الاولى وتابعت بالقول ميسي يفشل في
تحقيق الفوز ضد السعوديه في احدى مفاجات
كاس العالم حيث خصيره الارجنتين لاول مره
في اخر ثلاث سنوات اما صحيفه الجارديانا
البريطانيه فعلقت الدوسري بطل صدمه زلزال
في المونديال وتبعت السعوديه تصدم
الارجنتين بهدفين متتاليين وتلحق بها
الهزيمه صحيفه ماركه الاسبانيه قنبله
ناريه تاريخيه في وجه الارجنتين فيما كتبت
صحيفه وديبورتيفو الاسبانيه ايضا ضربه
قويه للارجنتين امام السعوديه اما صحيفه
انت البرازيليه فقد وضع تعليقا طريفا على
النتيجه بقولها شكرا للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه جعلتم صباحنا جميلا في البرازيل
شكرا لكم من 200 مليون برازيلي
هي اذا مباراه ستبقى راسخه في اذان
المشجعين السعوديين والعرب وفي كل انحاء
العالم بعد ان كتب الاخضر السعودي بدايته
في المونديال بمداد من ذهب
دربنا اخضر العربيه
تشير الى ان عدد المصابين بالحصبه في 20
21 بلغ 89 شخص توفي منهم
128.000 المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه دراسه
19 فقد تاثرت برامج التحصين ضد الحصبه
وبشكل خطير
الختام تذكيرا بالعالم
مجلس الحقوق الانساني والبرلمان الاوروبي
يبحثان اليوم انتهاكات ايران لحقوق
الانسان
البنت تكون يقول ان العمليه التركيه في
سوريا تضعف التصدي لداعش وتهدد سلامه
العسكريين الامريكيين
وبغداد
مشرق قواتها على الحدود مع ايران وتركيا
بالتنسيق مع حكومه كردستان
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]